hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
i'd love to get to 15 000 subscribers
this week
and i need each and every one of you so
if you got a second hit that subscribe
button
ding i don't have the little like ding
icon so i just thought i'd add it myself
anyways today i am going to be reacting
to creepy men fight tooth and nail for
these women
if i'm being honest um i have never in
my life
been hot enough to like benefit from
creepy guys but i'm pretty sure these
are like only fans girls
okay so um there's a candy store
okay and the candy store as soon as you
turn 18 you're allowed into the candy
store if you're a woman
okay as a man you're not allowed into
the candy store until you're 35 years
old
have 100 000 saved up and and you've
been to the gym for at least five years
consecutively
once you have these prerequisites you're
allowed into the candy store well
obviously as you guys
know this takes time to acquire you know
and you can you know
okay if this is true kevin samuels said
he had sex with like
i hope i can say that on youtube 38
women in college in one of his videos
you're telling me he wasn't allowed in
the candy store
at my college his d3 basketball team
they ran through our school you're
telling me they weren't allowed
i know the candy store is going to be
set guys ended up waiting you know 18
years plus right to get into this candy
store
meanwhile do they do they ladies are in
there since 18 years old you know you
guys are walking up and down the aisles
having all the candy you want 20 21 22
whatever it may be
you guys you start to figure out what
you like what you don't like you figure
out tootsie rolls are disgusting
the yellow flavor of laffy taffy is
strange and pink starburst is superior
do not like this that's right all these
little things gummy bears whatever
you tried to figure out do i like
chocolate do i like white chocolate
whatever
so you guys are having your fun in the
candy store having the candy that you
want
so you know 17 18 years later now the
men can come in at 35 they saved up
their money they've been in the gym
and they finally are 35 years old bang
they
run into the candy store they go nuts
but still taking every piece of candy
going wow like oh my god
they're eating all the tootsie rolls
that you guys left over they're
disgusting they're eating the yellow
laffy taffy the yellow starbursts like
everything right they're going nuts
right they're just running all over the
place
you know what i'm saying so uh and they
get the candy
and then you guys are looking at them
like bro what the hell is wrong with you
like it ain't that serious like why
you know what i'm saying why do you want
to eat all this candy i've been here
before
exactly you know what i'm saying and the
reason why women don't understand
that the men want to have multiple women
is that for men we have to fight tooth
and nail to get into this candy store
you know what i'm saying when
some men do if you're born like
six three
and with certain qualities like are just
allowed in you know i don't say that to
be uh also i'd like to say
they always talk to these stunningly hot
girls
have you ever once considered what it's
like to be born
average i never
look it i i would have loved to but i
never had a line of guys just
like i mean maybe i had more than like
some guys but like
all i'm saying is like
this isn't completely true toxic
whatever it may be it's that
women are born with value men must
create their value so when men are
finally able to
you're telling me that like that hairy
guy from too hot to handle
had no value like he's hooking up with
girls left and right
their value they're gonna go crazy
because so few men
actually get sexual access from women
from women and i know you guys might not
know this but like only about 10 to 20
of guys are having sex with all the
girls like 80 90 of the girls
yeah so in other words there's a lot of
eskimo brothers there's i'm sorry
there's a lot of eskimo sisters out
there
not many eskimo brothers i i've heard
that before
so it really depends like
you know what you're born into i'm just
saying like some guys
have have had sexual access from a very
young age
and those are usually the same ones that
justify like
candy store arguments are they usually
the same guys
that were allowed in the candy store at
a young age
so since women are all chasing this a
small percentage of men
these guys have all the they have all
the leverage and they're getting all the
girls your drapes your futures your
rappers your athletes okay
whatever it may be i'm sure you've
probably seen them at the club right and
i'm sure your colleagues like they're
those are type of guys they date
all the women are chasing these guys
right see the ladies are smiling and
they know yeah so
um so when a guy is finally able to
become and
be able to stay in the candy store he's
gonna take his time and eat as much
candy as he can because he has a fight
to get into there
so that's the analogy i always give to
women about why men always want
uh to have multiple women because it's
difficult to do let me add that as well
so also as well a lot of guys right that
are
i would say new entrepreneurs many
millionaires they're young right
so the canister is a back door and only
some guys get that back door entrance
because
they become millionaires at a young age
or they become successful they get
inheritance or something like that
so like youtubers gamers they're very
young and they're successful
so still remember you go on 18 years old
he's getting maybe like
20 22 23. so this is all new frame
either way so those guys we're always
catching up to you guys
always catching up so because if you
take a guy that's um
a 605 guy making half a million dollars
a year et cetera
he's not going to have nearly the amount
of options as a girl that's
you know average looking and has you
know i mean and
not even the hottest you know she he's
going to have half her options i
guarantee you guys but
you're talking about options to hook up
with not options to a relationship
women want a relationship guys want to
hook up with you
so like what type of if they're talking
about sexual options
sure but relationship options i
guarantee the guy making half a million
has more relationship options than the
average looking girl
guys opens up your phone you're going to
have 99 plus dm's in your instagram box
of guys trying to hit you up men yo real
talk
that's right you want me to bar right
what happens you go in the bar
let's say there's 20 guys right you say
you know what i hate to say it but i
guarantee my boyfriend
has more instagram dms hitting on him
than i do
who wants to have sex i guarantee you at
least mention them will say yes
but if you say who wants to be in a
relationship it'd be like that bar
who was out of sex you massaging this oh
how dare you
yeah it's like yo nick get out of here
so it's tough for guys
yeah it's tough man so that's why that's
why men um you know
that's why men go crazy because so i
feel sexual tension
between the girl with the long black
hair
and the guy you guys are actually
actually able to do it you look at rap
videos
like there's a reason why they have
different assortments of girls like men
look at sex
completely differently than women do and
this goes back to what i'm saying this
is why like when a
man like has sex with other girls it's
not that big a deal because it's
physical but you can still love your
girl
bang other chicks but it doesn't work
all the way around like that's not fair
i don't like that i'll say this it's not
fair that we can't sell food picks and
make money there you go
i mean you can't we're fresh
just so you know i'm coming out with my
own feet picks you guys
no but
you know what
guys can do that like they can
but do you think we should live in a
world where we should just
do whatever we want but realistically
speaking i know you're saying you can
but let's be realistic
men there's a lot of life isn't fair you
know i'm saying like
equality is is a lie you know what i'm
saying like men and women are completely
different there's privileges that men
have that women don't and vice versa i
argue that women have more privileges
than men do
nowadays in modern day world but that's
a whole other conversation but what i
will say is that
i know you're saying that's not fair but
it's also not fair that
and a 21 year old can get invited to a
party with rappers and millionaires
whereas a 21 year old guy would never
even get the chance
okay where are the girls that get
invited to these things
i have some pretty attractive friends
i don't know one girl that's been
invited to a party with millionaires
okay well i guess i guess i have but not
for the reasons that you think it was
just because my dad was invited and i
got to go with him
okay but like i never got invited to
like yachts
or really yeah
like they only talk about it from a hot
girl perspective
and i know i'm cute but i was i never
had drake in my dms you know what i mean
you know so
there's there's positive negatives on
both sides everywhere so that's that's
what it is
um cool very cool but that's a good
question though that's good
i mean does that make sense kind of you
know no it does yeah i mean i may not
agree but it does make sense and i kind
of like do see it from a different
perspective
but and i'm just telling you why you
know what i'm saying like we can
obviously have respectful discourse we
don't have to agree
but i'm just telling you from the male
perspective like this is why men do that
right
it's definitely good to hear it from
like a male perspective like
get a difference because most why i mean
that makes sense but again what is your
character is it worth like selling your
soul
for something like that do you know what
they're gonna tell you you're an
attractive young lady they're to say
oh no girl i ain't like that like you
know what i'm saying i love you no i'm
saying it's okay
they're going to whisper those sweet
nothings in your ear
but he just assumes everyone thinks like
he does
let me know in the comments maybe some
guys don't but
i know guys that are like genuinely
repulsed by the cheating
like generally i'm gonna take care of
you i'll take care of you
guys
people really be going the extra mile
just to like they're crazy
yeah tell us the craziness
go ahead i miss venezuela oh sorry okay
ecuador ecuador sorry so
okay so i wasn't like at work or
anything i was just in a normal
nightclub and this man came up to me
and he was looking at my skin and he was
like wow like your skin is just so
beautiful
it's so soft i'm like yeah thanks and
he's like i would just love love to
taste your skin
and i'm like what hold on wait wait at
this point hold on so
get detected
like a hannibal like hannibal
yes like he literally told me he was
like i would just love to
take a bite of your skin and just feel
it with you and i'm like
ah like what what do you even mean and
he's just like
yeah literally and he was like i just
want to take you home
like seduce you and everything and then
just take a nice taste of your skin
yeah that is a true story i swear to god
okay you know what man i'm gonna say
this real quick because
over here at the pressure pit podcast we
hold both genders accountable
we clown we you know we make we make
jokes on women and we also make jokes on
weird [ __ ] too
bro and i have never heard that one
that's the first one when i tell you i
ran and
i ran like i ran so fast
wait was there a vibe
okay listen i was just at like the small
bar in buffalo
and like you know he bought me a drink
whatever it was cool
yeah it was buffalo's weird i noticed
that's why
this makes sense yo he bought me a drink
you know we were just having a
conversation he just came out with that
i looked at him i'm like
are you for real and he's like yeah
after that i literally turned around so
fast walked right
out the bar i'm like that's what i'm
going home that's it that's nice
that was his own no like the opening
line was like hey can i buy you drink
whatever
and then like it started to get a little
conversation and then he just looked at
my skin and he just was rubbing it like
this
and i was like okay like you know it's
fine he touched you
literally touched my arm just up and
down i was like okay
and then right after that he hit me with
that line and i was like
yo is this man's for real
this is pikapine that was his pickup
line
i want to take you home seduce you and
get a taste i'm trying to think if i've
ever had a guy hit on me that weirdly
gosh it's been so long since i've been
like
been like in a situation like that i
can't think of one
skinniest pickle yeah that's that's
that's crazy bro
okay so did you smash them or not hell
no
i thought i got to go home after this
that's too much
let's hear your story so can you top
that one is the real question
so in the club like there's so random
guys
especially like the old guys you know
like they have like rare footage
so one guy wants me
to tell him like i'm her daughter you
know
and it was so [ __ ] weird really [ __ ]
oh yeah like he told me i want you to
behave like my daughter
and i was like uh i just really can't
do it you know so he wanted you to be
his like play role daughter
yes and smash you no
also he didn't even want like the he
didn't want the uh
no no no no no of course not because i i
was in the club you know
so what like he wants you to like what
no you want to take that
or some [ __ ] like what what did we do i
don't know he was telling me about her
daughter you know that he has a daughter
uh the daughter was 14 years old
so
okay i want you to be like my daughter
and i was like
how's your daughter and he told me okay
she's 14 years old
you have to talk like with a super sweet
boy he and tell me the things
so she wanted you to kind of speak to
him like super
sweet okay like like almost okay this is
getting strange
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's stop the story
o r n type of like content and that's
blowing up yeah basically uh yeah if you
guys know about this sound effect
yeah basically shout out to uh i
actually don't know what that sound
effect is
exactly for the people that know um but
yeah bro like there's a lot of weirdos
that like that type of um
that is spicy entertainment if you know
what i'm saying i don't want to use a p
word but uh yeah okay you definitely
thought that i will give you the um uh
definitely the
okay that's kind of
okay i think that's pretty much the end
um
this is a cool video
i never had a problem with guys being
that creepy to me
maybe maybe i did and i just don't
remember but let me know your creepiest
experience with a girl
or a guy in the comments don't forget to
subscribe
i'll talk to you guys next time